はい、というわけで今ですね。
えっと今日あったU-FES2017が終わって
帰ってきたところでございます
ただいま、ただいま
打ち上げさぼっちゃった
なので今日この場を借りてU-FESにきてくだっさたみなさま
そして出演者の皆様、スタッフの皆様
本当にお疲れさまでした
いやー
すごかったっすね
も～毎年そのU-FESっていうイベントが
どんどん大きくなってって
もう、でかすぎてちょっと
ビビるわ！
やっぱ皆さんとお会いできるいい機会だし
まーいつも動画を見てくださてる皆様に何らかの形で
なんかこう返せればいいと思って
直接会う機会ができて、とてもうれしいし
とても楽しかったです！ありがとうございます
でなんですけどぉ！そのU-FESのイベントの中で
あの、U-1グランプリ！
UUU-1グランプリっていう企画があって
実は時間、なんとか作って
1分の動画を作りました
何人かのクリエイターさんが一分の動画を作って
その中で一番
「続きが気になる！」っていう動画を作った人に
1000万円が当たるっていうコンテストが
今日あったんですけども
グランプリに
輝いたのは
[ドラムロール]
エントリーナンバー
3番
はじめしゃちょーでーす
はじめしゃちょー！おめでとうございます！
1000万当たりましたーーー！！
[拍手]
やっべーなおい
やべーよ…1000万
誰かに自慢しよっと
はじめ：もしもし～？
まさき：はい
はじめ：ねーまさき？
はじめ：1千万円もらったよー
まさき：おめでとー
はじめ：いえーい
まさき：え？すごいね
はじめ：やばいよね？
まさき：うん…
はじめ：で、何に使う？
はじめ：何に使う？
まさき：え、動画に使う用でしょそれ
はじめ：そう
まさき：え、なんか1000万あったら
なんか結構な機（材…
[通話終了]
無事というかまぁお金がすべてでは
ないんですけれども
みんなで一つのテーマに向かって
競い合うっていうコンテストで無事、優勝できて
良かったでございます。
でまあホント僕が出した動画っていうのがですね
実際会場に言った人しか見れてないと思うので
ぜひ、ご覧ください。どうぞ！
待てよ
その服装はやばいよ
おしゃれにキメて
かっこよく渡そうぜ
頭、服装、香水、完璧さ。
どこにいる？
可愛い子？あっちです。
サンキュー
はじめ　住所
特定してやったぞ
アンチ共よ、
今はそれどころじゃない。
どこにいったの？
ひと目で落ちたぜ
プリンセス
ハンカチと
オレのハートを
君へ
あぁー
見つけたぜ
プリンセス
はい！というわけでこういう終わり方でございます
とりあえず女の人の顔見てーなって
思わせたいっていう作戦です
いや、この動画ですね、すごい振り付けとか
あの僕何もない
ただミュージカルっぽい音楽に歌詞を自分でつけて
ダンスやってた人と振り付け考えて
カメラマンの方とかに手伝ってもらったりして
実際にそのミュージカルに出てた
皆さん、後輩とかなんですけど
まあ、ホントに僕一人の力じゃ
絶対とれなかった賞だったんで
あのー…みんなの協力のおかげで
僕のやりたいことができたと思っております
ほんとにありがとうございます
そして、続きが見たいと思ってくれた皆さんも
ありがとうございました
で！
問題はここからだ
あの、1千万円マジであたった
みたいなんですけど1千万円
どう使えばいいですか？
いや、ほんとに結構困ってるんすよ
1千万円の使い道が
最終的には自分で決めると思うんですけども
まあ、機材とか買うとか
つまんな！つまんなあ！
機材買うとかはちょっと、さすがにつまんないーけど
まあ実用的ではあるけれども、まあ
ちょっと、今んところは置いといて
なんかこう面白いことに使えれば
いいな、と思っております
まあ参考までに皆さんの意見も
ちょっと聞いておこうかなとか思ったりしているので
良かったらコメント欄で1千万円あったら
何の動画を取りますかっていうのを
よかったらコメント欄に書いておいて下さい
ちょっと、参考にしたいくらいなので
ちなみになんか、
動画制作のためしか使っちゃダメなんで
私利私欲の為には、使えないのが非常に残念です！
はい、というわけで私は今
動画に使える1000万円を持っている
ハッハッハッハッ…
っは！
というわけでホントにUFに来てくださった
皆様ありがとうございました
明日はゆっくり1千万円の使い道でも
考えるわ！